wo ist seit dem 9 september fehlt von
der 26-jährigen förmlich jede spur
eigentlich wollte sie mit rucksack und
zelt alleine den 119 kilometer langen
schlucht in staig im schwarzwald
erwandern jetzt die sorge ums galette
die ist natürlich groß und mit jedem tag
wird die hoffnung weniger skelett
unversehrt wieder zu finden bild
reporter sebastian prengel ist an dem
ort wo die 26-jährige zuletzt gesehen
wurde sebastian was ist denn das
gefährliche an diesem weg den sie gehen
wollte man also den schluchtensteig ist
ein sehr beliebter wanderweg hier im
südschwarzwald
er gilt aber auch als sehr anspruchsvoll
sind heute selber auf diesem weg
unterwegs gewesen und man muss sagen er
ist an vielen stellen nicht breiter als
ein schmaler trampelpfad und da muss man
wirklich aufpassen dass man nicht aus
denn ein zeit schritt und man stürzt
möglicherweise mehrere hundert meter in
die tiefe das sind ja hier steilhänge
mit einem gefälle von mehr als 70
prozent auch unser fotograf ist heute
ausgerutscht und gestürzt und hat sich
dabei leicht paletten das zeigt einfach
wie gefährlich ist hier ist er das gilt
auch für erfahrene wanderer erst recht
wenn sie alleine unterwegs sind
scalas wird jetzt schon sehr lange
vermisst sucht die polizei noch nach der
frau und wenn ja wie also es ist so die
polizei hat natürlich mit einem
großaufgebot nach der junge august mit
hubschraubern mit wärmebildkameras mit
drohnen auf 35 bundes sind im einsatz
gewesen
es ist aber auch so dass die suche jetzt
mittlerweile eingestellt wurde es gibt
aber immer noch hinweise und diesen
hinweisen gehen die polizei natürlich
auch noch nach man hat mir fast das
gesamte gebiet abgesucht bis auf einen
streifen von circa 20 kilometern länge
da ist das gebiet sei unwegsam da kommt
auch die polizei nicht hin das sind
steile felswände tiefe schluchten dann
müssten sich höhenretter abseilen
das geht aber nicht auf gut glück
sondern dafür braucht es hinweise wie
gesagt ihnen geht die polizei nach
man muss natürlich aber auch ganz klar
sagen die hoffnung schwindet und stunde
zu stunde aber genau das ist es was die
lage hier so dramatisch macht denn es
ist einfach nicht auszuschließen dass es
tatsächlich abgestürzt ist und irgendwo
schwer verletzt auf hilfe warten mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dir das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren